eu sou professora de séries iniciais
trabalho com uma turma de 3º ano do
ensino fundamental
eles têm entre 8 e 9 anos e todo
professora dora uma pergunta e foi por
isso que eu trouxe uma pergunta pra
vocês o que você vê essa pergunta parece
comum para a maioria das pessoas em se
tratando de um olhar biológico mas hoje
a gente vai falar para além daquilo que
é biológico nós vamos falar de um olhar
humano acerca das relações sociais
o ato de ver ele não não é natural
na verdade o ato de enxergar o biológico
ele vem com todos os sentidos que os
seres humanos têm visão tato olfato
paladar audição mas o ver que é a
questão poética a essência humana ela
vem com o aprendizado vem com o nosso
desenvolvimento
eu fui diagnosticada aos cinco anos com
uma lesão no nervo óptico quando era
criança eu pensava que todas as crianças
enxergava como eu não via há diferença
nenhuma entre as relações com as outras
crianças
só comecei a entender que o mundo era
diferente
depois que o que eu cresci fiquem mais
mocinha adolescente e aquilo me
revoltava muito porque não entende
porque eu era tratada com indiferença e
porque eu era diferente eu busquem
respostas na religião na ciência mas
nenhuma delas me convenceu tanto quanto
as respostas que estavam dentro de mim
eu mudei a minha pergunta de por que
para com qual finalidade
e depois dessa mudança de perguntas eu
comecei a enxergar as respostas dentro
de mim eu percebia que não era a fala da
outra pessoa o modo
o que a outra pessoa me tratava com
desprezo e preconceito que me constitui
enquanto ser humano mas era a essência
que eu carregava dentro de mim e para
além de uma deficiência visual eu era
humana eu era eu sou cidadã de direitos
e deveres
eu tenho um papel fundamental na
sociedade não precisa ser incluída nessa
sociedade porque eu já faço parte dela a
minha deficiência não é aquilo que
exclui quando a gente pensa assim é
porque nós carregamos uma deficiência
as verdadeiras deficiências são as de
caráter
agora as que comprometem a nossa
condição física ou a condição
intelectual outros sentidos são apenas
biológicas
existe um pensador na pedagogia que
inspira né a pedagogia que se chama
bigode ski e ele diz que vai chegar um
dia em que as deficiências não serão
mais apontadas e que serão apontadas as
pessoas que estão ali ali na deficiência
que são cobertas por aquela camada de
preconceito que a sociedade trás mas que
um dia essa camada vai vai sumir vai
acabar
e aí a gente vai conseguir ver realmente
o sujeito de potências que existem que
existe ali
através dele eu terminei o meu ensino
fundamental com muita dificuldade
ingressei no ensino médio sofri
violência física psicológica
fui agredida verbalmente por várias
pessoas e de vários modos eu acho que se
eu fosse listar os apelidos pelos quais
eu fui chamada não sairia daqui hoje mas
não foi nada disso que me construiu
aliás isso foi fundamental para
descobrir quem realmente quem eu
realmente sou
e aí eu queria continuar estudando tinha
uma paixão enorme pela escola
eu já ouvi de professores no em toda
minha trajetória que não seria
interessante me ensinar porque uma
pessoa que enxerga muito
não entender nada sobre o mundo então
não precisava aprender muitas coisas por
que ler e escrever já era suficiente mas
pra que descobri física química e depois
de mesmo assim eu sempre me esforcei
porque eu não queria ficar atrás de
ninguém eu sabia qual era o meu lugar
a gente precisa legitimar o nosso lugar
na sociedade que precisa mostrar o nosso
espaço ea ingressem no ensino superior
na verdade o meu intuito era ter cursado
psicologia porque eu acreditava que a
psicologia ea me dá uma o embasamento
que eu precisava pra continuar me
descobrindo mas eu não era independente
eu necessitava muito das pessoas para me
levar me trazerem e isso me trouxe um
grande prejuízo
então o que eu pensei eu vou estudar
numa faculdade melhor localizada perto
de pontos de ônibus e aí eu vou ficar um
semestre no curso de pedagogia e depois
que começar a me acostumando sozinha
teve independência é eu vou mudar de
curso vou estudar o que eu quero
não foi nada disso que aconteceu na
verdade eu me apaixonei pelo curso de
pedagogia
porque eu entendi que o profissional da
educação é aquele que vê além das
dificuldades é aquele que enxerga além
das possibilidades que faz a sua parte
para que o outro consiga chegar onde
onde é necessário chegar pois é os
estúdios me trouxeram esclarecimento
muito grande e eu fui me descobrindo e
eu fui também trilhando meu caminho
pensando em que tipo de profissional que
eu gostaria de ser
qual é o tipo de professor que eu
gostaria de ter tido né
no meu na minha trajetória no ensino
fundamental e médio e eu estava e eu
sempre pensei sempre me preocupei em
como eu poderia me comportar diante dos
meus alunos como seria o meu trabalho
qual seria o impacto do meu trabalho da
minha presença na vida deles
eu me formei em pedagogia
dia e lutei pela busca no mercado de
trabalho mas não foi nada fácil
hoje em dia a gente encontra muitas
vagas sim para pessoas com deficiência
mas não são na área da educação
e eu comecei a trabalhar numa empresa
muito grande muito bacana eu eu
trabalhava como assistente
administrativo ambiente era muito legal
é era adaptado às minhas necessidades
mas eu não estava feliz
eu não me sentir realizado aí eu fiquei
sabendo de um processo seletivo para
professores que acontecia na minha
cidade perré tá aí a oportunidade de
trabalhar naquilo que eu amo naquilo que
eu sempre quis e nenhuma escola me
aceitava então eu ingressei no processo
seletivo com muita esperança de ser
chamado mas nenhuma certeza pedir
demissão do emprego
meu chefe falou como assim você vai sair
daqui pra um lugar se você que você nem
sabe se vai ser convocado eu falei eu
sei porque eu acredito
quando a gente acredita tudo dá certo e
aí eu comecei a trabalhar quando a gente
descobre o que existe dentro da gente a
gente consegue mudar o mundo ao nosso
redor
a gente deve perceber quem a gente é a
nossa essência olhar para além daquilo
que é possível quando eu entrei na sala
de aula me veio uma angústia muito
grande eu encontrei uma turma muito
desordeira crianças muito bagunceira eu
achei que eu ia sair sem ruins em um
fígado não sei eu fiquei desesperado no
caminho para casa eu fiquei será que eu
vou amanhã acho que não volto amanhã
será que eu vou amanhã é meu deus
e aí eu me lembrei das minhas
dificuldades dentro da escola e pensei
será que eu volto amanhã todos os dias
quando eu era criança todos os dias eu
me perguntava será que eu tenho que
amanhã a escola e aí me veio à tona a
idéia de fazer com que a minha posição
enquanto professora fosse relativa
aquilo que eu queria
ter tido quando eu estava nessa idade e
na idade escolar
eu pensei assim eu preciso transformar o
desejo dessas crianças pela escola numa
coisa positiva
preciso mostrar a elas que a escola não
é um lugar de baderna de bagunça não é
um lugar só para você encontrar os seus
colegas mas a escola é um lugar de saber
e que o saber não acontece só por causa
das cadeiras enfileiradas ou dos livros
ou das apostilas das atividades serão
focadas
mas acontece na vivência do dia-a-dia
acontece em conhecer a pessoa que está
do seu lado a pessoa que está aí a
frente é uma relação de confiança e
respeito um outro dia eu voltei com esse
intuito de fazer diferente
sentei com eles a gente fez uma roda no
chão e ele já estranharam porque nunca
viram uma professora sentar no chão e eu
contei pra eles da minha dificuldade e
todos prestaram atenção em mim ficaram
extremamente curiosa e fizeram perguntas
muito pertinentes quem escolhe suas
roupas
como é que você usa um garfo faca colher
como você sabe o que você está comendo
como você estudou e chegou até aqui
aí eu ensinei a eles uma coisa que eu
aprendi em toda a minha vida
a gente precisa ter força de vontade
independente daquilo que é possível ou
impossível fazer a gente precisa ter
força de vontade de levar à frente os
nossos desejos e não deixar nos abalar
pelas dificuldades que a gente vai
encontrar na vida e eles ficaram
estagiados e faziam tanto as perguntas
que eu nem conseguia responder porque
eram muito complexos nem eu tinha parado
para pensar como você reconhece sua mãe
como você sabe que sou eu e eu fui
ensinando a eles que eu sabia quem era
quem pela voz e pelo jeito
tudo o que eu senti uma energia
diferente que vinha de cada um deles
ficaram impressionar
essa foto tentei explicar a gente porque
quando isso saiu no jornal os amigos não
liga
meus ligar e falar acessará como assim
você está apontando para um negócio em
cima me inscrever em baixo que rice foi
assim a menina que está atrás fez uma
pergunta e eu estava respondendo
enquanto o fotógrafo captou esse momento
e o menino falou tia está respondendo
aqui embate
e foi assim que aconteceu é depois
dessas mudanças dessa conversa desse
conhecimento um do outro que aconteceu
lá na minha turma a a gente teve uma
melhora super positiva super
significativa
hoje eles são crianças extremamente
prestativos amorosas e respeitosas
ajudam ao outro e depois disso é os
outros colegas de trabalho viram que a
turma era completamente diferente depois
que eu entrei
isso foi legal porque o meu
posicionamento refletiu na na vida dos
meus alunos
o novo olhar o olhar mais amoroso mais
fraternal refletiu de maneira tão
positiva que eu recebi outros alunos da
mesma turma com autismo inclusive porque
os alunos não um principalmente um ele é
autista não verbal ou seja ele não se
apropria da palavra para se expressar
o corpo dele fala as reações dele falam
e deram a idéia de colocar na minha
turma eu pensei caramba como eu com 2%
divisão vou entender o corpo dele fala
gente não tem coisas se nós e agora com
que eu vou fazer eu tive que partir para
assim ser idade
olha eu não enxergo direito ele já
levantou aqueles olhinhos redondezas
miami é sério verdade eu não enxergo
direito eu sei também que você não gosta
muito de falar não é
ele balançou a cabeça dizendo que sim
então eu vou me aproximar de você e nós
vamos manter um contato
bem próximo porque eu vou entender tudo
o que você quer me dizer
hoje em dia ele me beija coisa que ele
não faz com a família dele
esses dias ele fez um desenho e ele
sempre quando desenha ele se desenha
sozinho desenho muitas formas
geométricas porque ele adora autista é
tem sempre assim uma coisa que ele ama e
se dedica ele ama forma geométrica jogos
com formas geométricas e tudo e eu
estava olhando um desenho dele tinha um
coração tinha um boné que eu tinha uma
bonequinha
só que todos os bonecos que ele faz são
só a mesma coisa ele vê é as pessoas da
mesma forma ele não vê diferenciação
entre homem e mulher ele não aponta nos
desenhos e nesse desenho e apontou uma
diferença eu perguntei nossa que
gracinha quem é essa aqui aí ele olhou
será que você não sabe te a sara e
escreveu sarah e eu falei quem é esse
menino é que ele pedro e escrever o nome
dele e eu percebi naquele momento que eu
fazia parte do mundo dele que o mundo
dele não era apenas ele e tudo o que ele
gosta mas tinha um espaço pra mim também
e essa foi a parte mais gratificante é a
parte mais gratificante do meu trabalho
é saber que os alunos me olham com olhar
de a minha professora tem deficiência
professora é cega minha professora baixa
visão
mas eles me olham com olhar especial
como se eu realmente fizesse parte da
história deles bigodes que diz que nós
somos sujeitos históricos sociais
nós nos construímos através da história
e das relações com o outro e eu percebi
que a minha contribuição meu trabalho
fazia parte dessa construção
eu recebi uma cartinha de uma aluna
no primeiro mês que eu entrei estava
escrito assim tinha sara você é mais que
especial
não porque enxerga pouco mas porque eu
te amo
e eu percebi que o olhar da criança é
assim
vai chegar um tempo que as deficiências
não serão mais apontadas mas serão
apontadas as pessoas que estão ali
através de deficiência
as mudanças no mundo dependem da gente
porque se a gente não mudar o mundo vai
continuar o mesmo a gente sempre
reclamar ea sociedade está isso a nós
vivemos um momento de periculosidade
mas as mudanças vem de dentro da gente
se a gente não mudar o nosso olhar para
aquilo que é diferente daquilo que está
ao nosso redor do mundo vai continuar
sendo o mesmo mundo com as mesmas
deficiências com as mesmas dificuldades
com as mesmas impossibilidades
e é por isso que eu pergunto e aí o que
você vê dentro de você
às vezes a gente vê nas pessoas em nossa
como fulano é é desenrolado nossa é
inteligente mas existe uma inteligência
mobilidade
existem tantas potencialidades dentro da
gente a gente não pára pra ver o outro
pode ser reflexo da gente mas a gente
também é o reflexo do outro a nossa vida
tinge positivamente e negativamente a
vida das outras pessoas
por isso que a gente deve ver com
sabedoria esses dias eu estava lendo uma
frase que dizia assim se a sua
existência não tocar positivamente a
vida das pessoas que estão ao seu redor
então a sua vida inteira não valeu a
pena
é importante ter um novo olhar
arrisque se busque hoje porque não 11
usar outros olhos muito obrigado
[Aplausos]